right now metro police on the scene of a
police shooting on the east side of town
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis this all
happened just after eight o'clock
tonight not too far from eastern
and charleston orkomana joining us live
from that area the very latest on this
active investigation
orco well brian and denise metro police
are calling this a dynamic situation
and we are here on the scene a little
further away from where
exactly the bulk of the investigation is
going on now officers
are not telling us yet if anyone has
been injured or what exactly happened
and as i mentioned we are here
in this area there's still a police
presence over here
but we are being told that the bulk of
the activity is further on charleston
now here's what we know
right now metro police are investigating
an officer-involved shooting
near charleston and mojave again there's
quite a bit of police activity along
charleston heading east from fremont
again officers are calling this a
dynamic situation
people who live in the area say they're
concerned but this isn't completely
surprising
a scale of one to ten is probably a six
or seven
you know it's it's you see it every once
in a while
again metro police are conducting a
police investigation right now into the
shooting and there are still
not a lot of details we have we again
are hoping to learn more from metro
police in
just a few minutes so be sure to stay
with 8 news now for any updates
also if you're heading east on
charleston from fremont
be prepared for some road closures
reporting live in las vegas tonight
orca mana 8 news now